welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the worst can
opener you've ever had we're about to
open a can of worms with the best fan
theories before the finale
best jokes as well by the looks of it
throughout this video we'll be
discussing who Dolores is contact maybe
in Berlin who Ciroc smell is how Heil
managed to recover so well why Rehoboam
allowed the rebellion to happen and many
many more now there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't watched
up to episode 7 of season 3 yet then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as you don't want to miss our breakdown
on the finale and without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's dive
into some of the best fan theories on
Westworld season 3 ok so firstly you
will be discussing who's head the key to
the forge is actually in throughout the
season it's been told to us that Dolores
has it within herself and Ciroc has sent
Maebh after her because of it he of
course also wants to stop the rebellion
but taking her down will really complete
his end goal and kill two birds with one
stone
everyone seemingly believes that it's in
Dolores his head but it seems far more
likely that the key is actually within
Bernard firstly when we saw his pearl it
was laced with a reddish color whereas
the others weren't hosts pearls are
black and human ones tend to be red and
thus this showed a combination of the
two
perhaps hinting at the direction that
the show will be going in in the future
maybe Bernard and Arnold are now
combined but there's definitely
something going on with the character on
top of this there's really no other
reason for Bernard to be out in the real
world if he's not part of Dolores his
plan in some way we've discovered
throughout the season that she smuggled
out copies of herself and Bernard though
it was stay that he was put in place to
stop her should she go too far this
seems like a really strange strategy in
episode 5 genre when discussing his
sacrifice Connells told Bernard that he
was irreplaceable and this points to the
fact that he has a greater purpose it
does make sense that the Loras would
Jeep's iraq into going after her in
order to provide a distraction while she
holds her ace in the hole so yeah I do
think
it comes down to it this will be a big
reveal for the finale out of all of the
theories on the list I think this is the
most likely which is why it's up top the
Loras could have stopped Bernard at
several points but instead she decided
not to and from this we can gather that
there is a plan for him in the future
also serac has managed to capture a copy
of Dolores and surely if she was a copy
she would also have the forged key
within ahead and I don't know it just
doesn't make sense to me but yeah I
definitely think something is up here
the next theory sort of ties in with
Bernard and that is who is Sir acts mole
early in the season when talking to
Charlotte ale serac stated that she was
in the only person that worked for him
and this hinted at him having others
embedded within the key character groups
the most likely of these is of course
Stubbs Stubbs is a host and can
therefore be controlled but he's also
exhibited some behavior that has played
his hands slightly for example in the
aforementioned episode when Connells was
with Bernard Stubbs managed to sneak
into sir axe highly secure compound and
catch up with the two how he was able to
do this is lightly because he was
granted access he's also the only person
that's been with Bernard the entire time
and it's unlikely that it's Bernard so
he can then assume that it's Stubbs as
he's the only other option it may be
Bernard but out of the two I'd say
Stubbs is the most likely especially as
we don't know what he was up to in that
motel room unless it was watching get
hot with a fembot 9 which is highly
recommended here on the channel anyway
the last time we saw the pair William
was holding a shotgun to the both of
them from next week's episode it looks
like the character is unloading it and
it could be that Stubb saved Bernard
from death by sacrificing himself one of
his current cornerstones is to protect
Bernard and he cost and this would cause
a conflict with his mission from serac
we've seen throughout the series that
this can lead to an awakening and it
could be the final play by the character
this is also a theory that I'm quite
certain on but he may not be the only
mole out there
similarly Kaleb could be a spy himself
now apologies to whoever pointed this
out in the last video I tried for about
half an hour searching for your comment
but I couldn't find it
but yeah give yourself a no prize for
dropping this they say that the show is
clearly providing biblical references
with the use of Solomon and
album therefore we can look to Caleb too
and how his name ties in with a good
book in the Bible Caleb was one of the
twelve spies sent by Moses into Canaan
so from this we can guess that Caleb is
a spy that has been unknowingly sent in
to collect data on Dolores we know that
he's partial to a bit of brainwashing as
he was integrated into a region center
and actually sent back out into the
world showing that the process did
indeed work
Caleb's already been used as a pawn by
serac so it makes sense that he would be
able to take him once more and use him
for his own agenda as stated with
Bernard
if serac really does have moles
everywhere then by the process of
elimination we can rule out Dolores
being the one in her group and therefore
Caleb fits the role I'm not too sure in
this one as we have just one episode
left and I can't see how it would be
revealed but it would really pull the
rug out from under everyone if the man
who is heading up the revolution was
actually unintentionally working as an
ally for the other side speaking of
allies one big question still remains
over the entire season and that is who
is the final Dolores pill in episode 7
Musha she sent a package to someone in
the country and as we don't know who the
fifth and final dolor I pearl is I think
de Laura is the right term we can guess
that it is indeed her but who could it
be
well though I said in my last video that
I think it steady since sleeping on it
I've had an even wilder theory what if
it's actually a copy of Sirach just just
hear me out for a second don't hit that
dislike yet so throughout the season
Dolores has been replacing real world
people with hosts in order to make her
grand play she did this in the case of
Charlotte ale and canals both of whom
infiltrated their positions really well
until they were discovered by serac now
it is possible that this entire time
Dolores has been starting the revolution
in order to draw Ciroc out so that she
could supplant him think about it before
all of this Ciroc was lying low and he'd
been completely removed from every
database on earth however Dolores
managed to draw him out into going
public so that he would reveal his face
to the world nobody knew what he looked
like
including Dolores and therefore she
needed to pull him into public so that
she could copy his face from here she
could then take him down and replace him
with her own
it thus gaining all of his power and
assets how crazy would it be if the host
went from being subservient to then
taking on the face of the world leader
who would send them from being the
slaves to the Masters and Dolores
definitely has a habit of doing this
another interesting theory that was
dropped in my video yesterday it came
from plam in TANF who stated that the
one in Berlin it may actually be the
real Dolores and this entire time we
could have just been watching puppets
makes sense for the real one to not put
herself in the firing line and to just
hang back while see this fight it out
perhaps that EMP blast did take her out
and the one we've seen in the previews
for next week is actually the true
Dolores that has come forth now we do
see her rebuilding herself we also know
that Mavis in the finale so it may not
be true but it's fun to think about
these theories often and in a way until
you realize they're not on you you cry
and everyone hates you now the next
theory involves Iraq and it's probably
the one that you've heard a million
times that is that the character is dead
and he is merely operating as a hologram
this is something I think we've all
thought about at some point but the
further things have gone on the less and
less likely it seemed due to the
character interacting with people in
order to discuss this I'm gonna bring up
a post on reddit that was dropped right
after episode 4 and then kind of expand
on it the initial point was dropped by
Kings leap and he tied it in with Sir
acts origins story in the aftermath of
the attack on Paris we see people in
hazmat suits calling for serac and his
brother to come with them the body of a
cow dead on the ground lies besides Iraq
as he looks over the explosion and
clearly the pair were exposed to massive
amounts of radiation they actually made
their own way into the surrounding
villages and thus were given no
protection from the insane amounts of
radiation that they were likely
subjected to it is possible that the
pair worked on Solomon together but you
did the excessive amounts of damage done
to them their lifespans were severely
shortened thus serac froze his brother
and then finished Rehoboam himself he
died shortly after and then Rehoboam
took on his form in order to interact
with the world this would explain why
Solomon has similar personality traits
as John me
whereas Rehoboam does not I'll play a
clip in just a second but please pay
close attention to it as we'll be
discussing it later on
to go into this with the mind stay that
serac is already dead and that Rehoboam
has his form and it makes a lot of sense
if you're saying this that means you
have a working brother our little
experiment has worked
the message for the Damned we hope on
solving you and those like you the
outliers the fatal flaw that would have
bent the world on its axis it needed
time in the right set of genetic
information to restore you you are now a
better version of yourself rough edges
rub smooth the longer a danger to the
world or yourself I wish I could be
there with you drumming but man I was
the longer exists
okay so the main point to take from this
for now is that serac states that the
mani was no longer exists thus it is
possible that the character died and we
are merely seeing a projection of him
and where this falls down is that we
have seen the character interact with
people and he even shot someone in the
head however it is possible that he is
either in a house body which we know he
has the ability to create or that the
times he took people out it was merely a
simulation from the second episode of
the season we know that Maeve was in a
simulation without realizing it for a
long time and later she too believed
herself to be in the sublime when she
was also part of a fake reality so Rach
could have created a simulated reality
in which we the audience and characters
were unaware of and thus he was able to
fool us all this will explain why Hale
had to Don a our glasses to see him at
the end of episode two and while he
constantly has appeared as a projection
throughout the series we do see in the
preview that caleb appears to be
strapped in to Rehoboam and this could
explain how serac is able to hold a gun
to his head now where this falls apart
is that during the Dallas takeover serac
is seemingly shot by Hale before
revealing he's a hologram and then we
cut to what looks like it's the real one
in Hales office it seems strange to have
a hologram within a hologram and just
overkill at this point so yeah whether
it's true or not we will see and then we
can add to the definition fan theories
that turned out to be untrue pile which
which is getting bigger every second now
before we get into the rest of the
theories I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the Marvel
phase 3 part 1 box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be one
the chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the updates in the comment
section below
then when it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of May and the set will be
shipped out from then to ever get to the
prize it's the best of luck that
everybody takes part ok so this theory
comes from mr. Trobe on reddit and like
the other ones I'll be discussing the
main points and then expanding on them
user went all the way back to Episode
one in which Liam Dempsey jr. spoke to
one of surak's henchmen played by pom
Clementi F in this conversation she
accuses him of testing Rehoboam and the
conversation quickly comes to the
conclusion that it's someone from within
the organization rather than from
outside it so we can rule Delores out of
it
pom thinks it's Liam but as we know from
the series over a lark he doesn't really
do anything and is so basic he even got
the t-shirt now this does cause us to
ask what is actually going on well it is
possible that serac actually planned the
rebellion in order to make Rehoboam
stronger we know that Solomon can make
changes on the fly and adjust its
calculations so it makes sense that
Robin would be able to do this too
therefore serac could have likely
countered Dolores his rebellion
countless times but he still allowed it
to happen this also explains why Solomon
was so poorly guarded and why it handed
over a complete doomsday strategy by
just being asked for it
serac said to me that he had been
waiting for the host to arrive and that
they weren't the real threat and that
humanity actually was this could be
referencing the Caleb actually is the
real one who will lead to the downfall
of it all this may be why Liam Dempsey
jr. said you did it and why Bernard said
that Dolores ought operates with poetry
if serac knew this would happen in
advance then he could predict that
Dolores as a lie would lead the
revolution and therefore he could plant
his own spy by her side and ordered have
someone that he could control the season
may actually end with Sir acts death but
then he could have also planned that to
hell the finale itself is even called
crisis theory going back to the message
left for his brother
the little experiment that Soraka is
referring to could be the host uprising
which would lead to his death and then
his brother wouldn't thaw and take his
place in controlling this system he
would have all of his edges smoothed out
at this point and therefore be ready to
lead it would be a big twist and for a
season that's been short of those I feel
like they're holding something off like
this until the finale and finally we'll
be talking about how Charlotte Hale is
okay after the explosion at the end of
episode 6 the character ended up looking
like
Anakin at the end of Revenge of the Sith
in episode 7 we see her shrouded in
shadow but slight burns
and we made-out around her face it is
possible that this is actually a
hologram as we see in the preview for
next week that she appears has wanted
Dolores well there are other
possibilities such as the healing pen as
well as her new companionship
hey leak the location of Musashi to
Maeve and therefore we can guess that
she got something in exchange
though her family are dead she may have
went to serac and pleaded with him to
create her a new one which he could live
out the rest of her days with serac his
host printing capabilities and the one
Arnold's house is now under his
occupation so she would likely have
little other options I believe that she
has switched sides unaware that serac
was behind the death of her family and
due to her belief that she was
expendable to Dolores she probably
assumed that she was the one behind the
bombing either way it's good to see her
back in the game and I'm sure the show
still has a few surprises left like like
Kayla being Ciroc brother I'm telling
you he saw Rock's brother yesterday I
was so sure that Salomon was Aaron Paul
putting on a French accent and then I
got a tweet about it this morning so
I'll look it up it's not Caleb it's
shown me we can rest now now obviously
I'd love to hear your theories on the
theories and if you think any will
happen if you want something else to
watch there make sure you check out our
breakdown of episode 7 which is gonna be
linked at the end and if you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below and hopefully you see
over there and hopefully we see over
there very soon this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you
[Music]